hey guys so today is kind of Oh a very
interesting very very random day I'm
hanging out with Garth Brooks because he
just joined social media so we're kind
of taking him around to Twitter and to
Facebook and letting him kind of learn
the ways of the internet so this has
been so fun watching the whole learning
process
watching him tweet for the first time
it's it's awesome so right now we are at
Facebook so we're gonna be doing a
little facebook chat and I don't really
know what's all going on so you'll see
in a second everything we do so and you
just joined Facebook today and if you
turn around with or a million likes
already so we're outside this is the
Facebook what is this this is well
campus but like does this have a name
here it looks like a little circus we're
going to get ice cream at Facebook like
this is like a little road I'm losing my
mind like I just don't even know how to
handle this right now not only were you
at Facebook but Garth Brooks is here
with us hanging out like rohini Oh Garth
Brooks are they like this is awesome
this is I'm having a great day
are you guys excited are you excited is
a greatest day of my life I'm pretty fun
so you can choose from baked goods or
ice cream or what are you gonna get I
don't know what they have a lot of
things there's a lot of options I can't
make a decision okay neither
bring at me
so we've now made it downtown to San
Francisco and we are going to Twitter
this has been so much fun so I'm really
excited to have Garth join Twitter and
be it Twitter tweeting at Twitter again
this is a twit inception say hi to the
Internet this is such a big day for you
I'm so excited
nice I'm not leaving Twitter and we're
going to charts I guess you could call
it a tweet up because he tweeted out
this is not like a secret show here a
lot of secrets situated it I'm sure
that's what we're heading to now there's
a long line of people from Garth's tweet
do we have used to be here so obviously
people shut up but that's how it works
it's magic all right guys that brings
Garth Day to an end
happy social media day Brian things
through haven't been coming for this fun
- Ben Burke oh this was so great make
sure you guys go follow Garth Brooks
like I like I was a guard fan but now
after actually meeting him and talk with
him and hearing these stories I love him
he's amazing
I look forward darlin specialist hi guys
and I just decoded some vibes I did I
was I was trying to give him some
lessons and now I think he's a pro he's
gone through the social media I J
training all right guys I gotta go to
bed doctor back to LA oh shoot oh my
gosh we're not even home
we're in San Francisco oh god I can't go
to bed yet